latéraux du post sachez le
on va pouvoir interroger sur jean pascal
ou moundir un tronc celui qui aura la
moyenne si vous avez la moyenne celui
qui est interrogé tout ira bien
celui qui n'a pas si vous n'avez pas la
moyenne vous serez habillés en costumes
dan jusqu'à la fin sinon vous avez la
moyenne ce sera moi mais d'accord
attention c'est parti on y va celui ou
celle qui va jouer avec nous tu sais
c'est c'est la roue est très longue mais
toujours aaa à aa
d'ailleurs tu peu à côté pour aller
benhaim attention bénin merci lll mais
plus longtemps que maxime gagné pour me
dire attention comment s'appelle le
conte le candidat contre ki-moon dire
c'était un peu énervé en 2009 dans koh
lanta le retour des héros
iata femmes sachent
la proposition n'est pas c'était pas
karim arrim non c'était qui il est
philippe est proche souvenez vous c'est
là des classes les plus célèbres de la
télé voilà c'était énorme c'est pendant
ce clash vous avez crié la phrase qui
restera gravé dans ma mémoire
ah ouais pourquoi tant de haine aucune
dignité aucun honneur et voilà c'est ça
résume ma vie à la télé je crois que mon
extrait télé préféré regarder les
aventuriers rouges ont décidé de vous
éliminer et leur sentence est
irrévocable forme ne veux pas que tu
étais à ma femme devant toi moi j'ai
mérité ma femme me dire j'ai aucune
leçon de morale à recevoir de thouars
eagles et moi tes notes voiture s p la
question qu'est ce qu'il ya on dira
c'est au play qui a maintenant question
maintenant dire s'il vous plaît sur
j'aime me dire non non pas du tout car
il est bien il est là ce soir
le tableau était d'ailleurs vous allez
écrire maintenant attention c'est parti
conclue t les paroles de la chanson
l'agitateur de jean pascal est payé par
coeur je suis un agitateur à provocateur
du boule de poils une bête à poils une
beinheim son poil mais je suis un
provocateur un nom c'est le mauvais
passer alors j'ai une boule de glace à
une bête à poil et boules de poils une
bête à poils une berry name son poil
aller vite vite vite et à poils non il
vous a aidée j'ai vu alors il est pas la
télé j'étais en zones définies et vous a
aidé on annule cette question écoute
l'animateur jean pascal était même été
le bon passage djerba malheureusement
cyril j'ai une question juste à temps
alors regarder un stagiaire qui a trouvé
parce que ça c'est pas ma voix c'est sur
internet sont dégroupés mais c'est pas
moi on a du mal je me prive de t'avoir
abascal approche du bien et j'enchaîne
les reproches je suis
l'agitateur provocateur
l'animal
jean pascal
l'agitateur
au bout de quatre heures
ne fait pas pâle
wen
et là ils nous avaient sans une question
attention attention bédié bout comment
jean pascal à dire comment jean pascal
at il réagi retournez vous retournez
vous retournez vous comment jean pascal
at il réagi quand il a perdu face à
mario en demi finale de la star academy
cl il a pleuré édition il a chanté ce
n'est qu'un au revoir
où il a passé le bonjour à vous le dire
il a pleuré ou quoi il a chanté ce n'est
qu'un au revoir mais déconner il a plus
rien c'est exactement ça maître nadjar
oui c'est une bonne réponse exactement
regardez moi je m'en rappelle gt gt pour
gt pour jean pascal taddei des scores
voilà la vérité j'étais pollet bailleux
était désormais des bodys s'ils étaient
tous à pas tout petit mario ce qu'il
était mario bros wii mais ni la forme
why are maintenant nous étions fâchés
mais que l époque là bas trois cadres
s'est engueulés nom n'est pas fâché on
avait besoin pourtant émission de fer
depuis quand on n'est pas fâchés car
refuser de venir dans l'émission parce
que tu étais là facile mais c'était dans
l'émission moi j'ai envie de refuser la
même jour de désir dans les messages que
vous êtes là aussi de notre camarade
repartira avec jennifer ce soir occupe
un duel suspense voici le résultat
[Musique]
bouger quoi
ouais
euh j'ai super dur parce que je voudrais
vous remercier parce que j'ai vécu deux
mois de mai super et et même si beaucoup
c'est un bon moment et d'être honnête et
c'est un travail assez risqué
c'était beau c'était vrai mais brest est
ce que la star ac vous manque
bah oui le débris s'était bel oiseau moi
je vois que j'ai voilà je vous le dis
j'ai regardé avant et puis après il ya
eu la version sur sur nrj 12 il me fait
très bon de leurs baux de logement dal
étaient bien visibles ces deuxièmes
féroé tnt après vous sur l'histoire la
tnt ouais je sais ah bah ouais bah merci
bah bravo à vous merci à vous et m
c'est la première fois que vous êtes
derrière moi j'espère que ce sera la
dernière pour vous parce que vous avez
23 dans est ce que la star ac et vous
regardez l'époque où j'étais tout petit
et pas si moi je me souviens je me
souviens de ton année mais on a vu quoi
cissé 2001 18 ans on avait sept 7 ou 8
ans et tous mi-temps et ouais et bien
mais je me suis bien gardé la nouille
julien doré a gagné témoin audience que
donc c'est la différence fait découvrir
la nouvelle star c'est benjamin castaldi
qui présentait après c était sa femme ou
bien dans le contraire on est entre du
tout ah non pas tant elle a présenté sa
série ici merci à vous annoncer que vous
avez pas pu être mariée que toumba
situation pétrole bondir gagner quand
moundir gagne une épreuve dans koh lanta
qui est très expressif ray mc idée dit
il toujours ses victoires en hurlant à
sa femme et envers les filles ont
vérifié gaza moundir c'est bon vous dire
vous rester dans l'aventuré
[Musique]
jean bras quelle galère est il arrivé à
jean pascal en plein direct sur le
plateau de la star ac
il a dû quitter le plateau pour aller
faire pipi mais la demande a stoppé la
chanson pour recommencer au lieu de jean
pascal
nikos la paix jean pastèque il a dû
recommencer
oui c'est dur commence à te dérange pas
alors c'est parti
[Musique]
jour même heure même temps
book excusez moi c'est indirect je crois
qu'il ya un petit problème ces avancées
homme peut vite tu vois j'ai fait c'est
à dire qu'est ce que c'était quoi tout
c'est bien une petite boulette assad
vert vient jamais de boulot et on dirait
qu'il sait la star ac est belle c'est
reparti on va se reconcentrer
non
et sans risque c'est que pendant le
direct c'était du direct il y avait
nikos y'avait mouchotte sur le plateau
le [ __ ] était là et elle nous jouons
pour le patron de tf1 le patron
d'universal et regarder et au moment où
je fois ils me regardent comme ça on va
le faire c'est et puis mon rien à dire
mais qu'est ce que tu fais ça tourne le
temps passe quoi c'est super et il me
faisait une tête d'henri iv n'est régi
par oui mais je me suis dit je vais me
faire taper témoin métiers tels apéros a
réussi alors ça compte qu'il fait aussi
demain tu chantais bien franchement moi
j'ai perdu beaucoup de distance alors
chanter chez un petit peu le cadre à la
remise a vendu beaucoup de disques
d'agitateurs facilitateur 984 millions
oui si tu as manqué juste après kerviel
et le cas eric hall 6 mois
[Rires]
dernière question pour vous mesdames ça
va chauffer
ado vous regardez mais c'est la question
me trotte pas parce que j'ai dit à trois
points non non j'en avais 5 2 2 fait pas
n'importe quoi la part on n'a pas posé
déjà 100 questions
vrai ou faux sur une chaîne il existe
une nouvelle émission qui va s'appeler
qui s'appelle d'ailleurs qu lanta ça est
tellement messieurs goethe et simple et
du coup allait venir moi dans les yeux
sur une chaîne
ça peut être une chaîne bah oui se
passerait alors non non non non et
pourtant et si la chaîne s'appelle
libido tv
il paraît que l'épreuve des poteaux et
très très attention à l'instant koh
lanta aura le bonnet d'âne elle praloup
alright le bonnet d'âne jusqu'à la fin
de l'émission ça s'est joué sur culotte
à la police mohamed ali
je dois vous dire
[Applaudissements]